bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france quelle est la
situation sanitaire aujourd'hui en
guadeloupe
la situation sanitaire en guadeloupe
elle n'a pas les vous le faites année
vous mais lentement
lily patients arrivent toujours de plus
en plus nombreux à vous
les commandez vers l'est de la france
que la france envoyait le cloud n'est
pas ni parole quelque chose de vain
puisque il arrive qu'ils allaient la
soulager les équipes déjà assurées sur
eux surchargé de travail
les gens continuent à mourir
les services qui a lancé l'idée c'est
que la télévision donc pas la télé bien
à la radio si elle mettait la mini avant
m quasiment une heure pour énumérer
égrainer la liste des morts nous vivons
en ce moment un boulot et inciter à
martigues d'ailleurs nous vivons un sale
moment et nous n'avons qu'une seule s'y
colle à la peau videur
affecté le maximum de nos compatriotes
et en espérant que le coup franc ce qui
prolonge par le préfet
de la guadeloupe a besoin aujourd'hui
pour faire face à cette situation
bas côté avant tout pour la besoin de le
10 12 10 de discipline en terre elle
encore dit puisque bon nombre de
patients sont encore jeunes coire les
services de réanimation sont dix ans
transporté transformer afin les services
de médecine je veux dire sans
transformer en lit de réanimation et on
sait très bien que la lan techniquement
ça devient compliqué pour pour ventiler
à évaluation
le l'hôpital de marc guadeloupe huit ans
après la défection il l'a pas besoin de
lits beaucoup de lit encore départ des
volontaires pour soulager les équipes
déjà en place le confinement a été
prolongée jusqu'au 19 septembre et c'est
l'une des solutions pour contenir la
propagation des variantes tha
je pense que le confinement assez
largement son sont ses preuves ici dans
l'hexagone et dans tous les pays qui ont
confiné mais qui ont confiné mais qui
ont vacciné à un moment donné la
pandémie enfin la progression du
variable et à seysses le drame c'est que
le valeurs delta sera populations qui
sont vaccinées une population qui est
des fientes envers les
trucs
décisions qui viennent qui proviennent
en tout cas de l'hexagone et qu' ils ont
pas ils ont compris maintenant je pense
que ça y est une idée de se faire
vacciner en tout cas l'idée que les gens
de plus en plus hubert il meurt de plus
en plus jeune a fait son chemin et que
il ya il ya quand même un début de la
vaccination qui qui se profile à
l'horizon mais le temps que la
population se fasse vacciner entièrement
je crains que d'autres lycées soit soit
comptée parmi a remis par mes nouveaux
patriotes de quoi ce look est aussi deux
matches vous dirais qu'il ya une prise
de conscience de la part de la
population depuis ces hausses de 4
contamination il ya quelques semaines
ça c'est une prise de conscience il est
un peu exagéré les gens savent
maintenant que les gens beurre puisque
des images montrant les morts plein un
circuit en guadeloupe ça peut choquer
mais en tout cas nous avons remarqué
qu'il y a le plus en plus de personnes
qui se font vacciner et qui se font
vacciner au grand jour alors que avant
on avait du mal à voir
comment est ce que vous expliquer que la
guadeloupe se soit retrouvé confronté à
une telle situation
alors il faut pas dissocier la
guadeloupe de la martinique
nous compatriotes ultramarins
sont
sont les premières victimes dix mesures
laxistes en tout cas du goddard laxiste
que l'état a pu avoir depuis des années
en termes le sanitaire n'oubliez pas que
le une femme dire ça n'a pas bien mais
lorsqu'un département ou des
départements sont frappés par les
problématiques de sarnez dans les
problématiques de chlordécone et que
l'on a on a l'impression que l'état
prend ça de manière légère on peut
s'attendre que comprendre que notre
nounou compatriotes soient devenus les
siens à voir résistant hostile aux
décisions de se faire vacciner et je
vous rappelle simplement une chose c'est
qu'en france hexagonale il y a de plus
en plus de gens qui se lèvent je dirais
à tort selon moi puisque la vaccination
a fait ses preuves et contre le vaccin
justement et que en martinique et en
guadeloupe qui sont des départements qui
sont exacerbées parce que on pourrait
dire le manière pudique une implication
une application à deux vitesses delà du
terme du triptyque liberté égalité
fraternité
nos compatriotes sont devenus méfiants
et
malheureusement il le paie ou plus fort
merci beaucoup daniel dalin président du
conseil représentatif des français
d'outre-mer merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation sur rtl france